big [__] takes time and I had to learn
that like I want you to feel that cuz it
took me a long time to learn what I see
happen all the time with entrepreneurs
especially when they apply to
acquisition. comom you know they've got
a million dollars in profit maybe it's
the bare minimum for for us to consider
for investment and they're like here's
my idea for how I an expand and how I
want your help I want to start all these
new product lines because I've already
saturated my market because I'm spending
$50,000 in Facebook ad and I can't spend
any more than I currently am otherwise I
lose the profitability of the ads so I'm
going to start selling more and
different offers and add massive
complexity to my business business that
only makes $3 million top line per year
that is a mistake and in this video I'm
going to walk through why and the reason
this is so important is because many
people hit this first plateau and then
think oh I should start a new business
oh I should start a new product line
when really they need to confront the
problem ahead which is they don't know
how to get more customers within their
current Niche or space your Market isn't
capped your mindset is capped what I'm
going to do is break down the three
different Frameworks I used to think
through this so that you are never
capped in whatever Market you go after
number one from from the marketing
perspective you have your method which
is the biggest thing you do it's running
paid ads it's making content it's doing
Outreach it's getting referrals it's
getting Affiliates those are the methods
that you do to get customers underneath
of that you've got the platforms that
you do that method on you've got
Facebook you've got phones email Hulu
YouTube You've Got Google ad underneath
of that you've got the media on the
platform so if I'm on Instagram I can go
Instagram DMs I can go Instagram stories
I can go Instagram posts I can go
Instagram reals I have all these
different media within the platform
platform one level below that is how
much volume am I doing within that media
am I posting one story a day one story a
week multiple stories a day multiple
post today so like that chiropractor
agency if there are a hundred other
agencies that market to chiropractors
and they're all marketing on Facebook
then you could probably add up all of
the ads spend of every one of those
agencies together and that just gives
you an idea of how much there is
available in terms of numbered new
clients per month that all of them
together are selling just on Facebook ad
rewind real quick if you're trying tock
pick what Market you're going to go in I
talk about this in my book $100 million
offers there's four things I want to
look at number one are they in pain am I
actually solving a problem for someone
number two are they easy to find cuz if
I can't find them I can't sell them
right number three do they have the
money to spend in order to buy my thing
because if I'm trying to sell to broke
people it's probably not going to be a
good idea number four are they growing I
don't want to be selling to newspapers I
want to be selling to something like old
people that are there's more of them
every single day that are retiring if I
have a market that checks all four of
those boxes then I know I'm at least in
a good opportunity now once I have that
in place and I looked at the four
variables that I talked about earlier
can I do a new method can I do it on a
new platform can I expand to multiple
types of media within the platform I'm
currently on can I increase the volume
that I'm currently doing in the mediums
that I have these are the things you can
do immediately to get more customers get
more leads today let's say you've capped
all of those things which is probably
not true but let's say you did because
we're going into Fantasy Land here I'm
going to introduce you to what I call
the Pyramid of markets there are five
directions that you can go in any
Marketplace to expand I'll tell you a
story of when I learned this I went to
this Meetup of eight entrepreneurs
together we were doing $500 million a
year in Revenue this was like a
multi-billion doll room which is kind of
cool and I was one of the smallest guys
there I think I was doing 30-ish million
a year at the time and they were talking
about their businesses I was like these
guys aren't smarter than me and I didn't
feel like they worked any harder than me
and I was like why are they making so
much more money than me two main factors
number one almost all of them have been
in business longer than me big [__]
takes time and I had to learn that like
I want you to feel that cuz it took me a
long time to learn all right there's not
many billionaires under 30 that made it
themselves like 10 in the whole [__]
world there's not a lot of them and fact
Checkers maybe it's 20 it's not a lot
the second lesson that I learned is that
all of them were going after bigger
markets than I was cuz at a certain
point you do saturate a niche and I'm
going to give you context to what that
means so gym launch was a licensing
company we specifically at the time only
focused on micro gyms now we do health
clubs and micr jyms cuz they expanded
The Market within that pie there was
only 50,000 micro gyms in the United
States we' already spoken with 20,000 of
them we had absolutely have really
maximized every media every channel we
call call we C email C to we run ads on
Google we runs on YouTube We runs on
Facebook we runs on Instagram we make
content like we do all the stuff and we
have really done a good job building a
market leading business there but again
it wasn't as big as theirs and that's
why we decided to open up another Avenue
now let me tell you about why we decided
to do health clubs so when we looked at
our adjacent markets we could have gone
down Market to personal trainers we
could have gone upm Market to health
clubs we could have gone to physical
therapists or chiropract was actually
very similar or we could have gone more
narrow those are the directions we could
have gone in I asked our our team one
question I said of these different
potential Avenues or avatars that we
could pursue who do we provide the most
value to by dollars made it was no
contest health club Owners we are able
to immediately make them like tens of
thousands of dollars within the first
like month by restructuring some of the
things that we could do within their
business and then doubling or tripling
their bottom line by reorganizing their
onboarding process reorganizing their
sales process how they handle retention
and how they handle upsells so if you
deal with hair salons maybe you sell
Consulting service you sell to salon
owners that's your current market you
can go in five directions number one is
you can go up Market that means on the
pyramid there are fewer people on the
higher part of the market and they cost
more but they spend more typically
higher quality customers that's where
you go into Enterprise sales we're
talking franchisors as in people who
have hundreds of locations under one
umbrella or multilocation or chain owner
that's up market for salon owners down
Market the second Direction you can go
is you go to hair stylist you talk about
people who are running chairs and doing
hair with their hands full-time not
running the business there's 10 times
more of them the third Direction you can
go is you can go adjacent so what's
something that's similar in nature but
not exactly the same that would be like
a lash and nails place if I were a
chiropractor it might be Physical
Therapy like they're similar but
different you want similar business
characteristics similar Avatar in terms
of the owner similar types of customer
within the same larger industry when you
do that that you just open up another
vertical and you attack it the same way
you did your first one the fourth
Direction you can go is you actually go
broader now imagine a pyramid that's all
the way like this and it includes all
the adjacent pyramids within it which
would then just be Beauty so that
includes medspot owners lash owners
massage studio like all of that kind of
falls in the same psychographic they
serve the same customer so that would be
going broader if we wanted to really
open up the net the last Direction you
can go is the only one that makes your
Market smaller but it doesn't
necessarily mean you make less money you
could become narrower instead of just
being all salon owners it might be salon
owners who specialize in extensions or a
blo hair place you know that they just
do the Brazilian Blowouts like they're
just doing that specific thing often
times when you do Niche down sometimes
you can still make more money because if
you're not even close to tapping the
methods the platform the media or the
total amount of volume you need to do to
reach all of those people within that
Niche and so then when you Niche down
become more specific with your messaging
your offer and the value delivered
because if you can make this one
specific Avatar 10 times more money than
the broad Avatar you should absolutely
Niche down on that and we've done this
with companies and doubled or tripled or
sometimes 5x the revenue in the business
despite cutting down who they Market to
by like 85% by getting really specific
about who we serve best big picture
zooming all the way back out if right
now you're not getting as many leads as
you want and you think that your Market
is saturated because of what you do you
should be looking the way an investor
looks at the marketplace and says this
is a $60 billion industry I have not
even 1% of this industry my whole point
here is you have your four initial
levers that you can immediately pull to
grow how many leads you're get it and
you probably haven't even done one of
them do one of them do another one of
them and then eventually try and do them
all usually there's this big checklist
that you probably already know as an
entrepreneur of what I call the should
do I know I should be calling my leads
faster I know I should be following up
better I know I should be making more
content I know I should start a Cod call
thing I know I should be running ads on
more platforms but you're not and if
you're like man that's going to take a
long time welcome to the main point I
had originally which is it takes time to
build big [__]